story breaking overnight the violence
between israel and the islamic militant
group hamas
in gaza is not letting up an israeli
airstrike on a house in gaza city this
morning killed at least 10 people some
of them
children that's the highest number of
fatalities in a single attack since the
conflict began less than a week ago
and while most of the most intense
assaults have been in gaza and southern
israel
a much wider offensive is taking shape
mts taya is in tel aviv with the latest
mts good morning jeff everyone good
morning just as we were preparing to get
on air
sirens started blaring over tel aviv and
we had to run
into a nearby bunker we could then hear
israel's iron dome system intercept
rockets
coming in from gaza but of course in
gaza
the bombardment by the israeli military
continues in a way
we've never seen before
israel's air and ground assault on gaza
continues with the ferocity unlike
anything seen before
overnight several areas of the densely
populated palestinian territory
home to two million people were pounded
in strikes
wreaking havoc this father clutches the
lifeless body of his child
screaming what has this baby ever done
across gaza and more horror as the death
toll surges to nearly 140
including 39 children while in israel
another night of incoming hamas rocket
fire
so far nine israelis have been killed
including the five-year-old
governments around the world are pushing
hard for a ceasefire
mark regev a senior adviser to prime
minister benjamin netanyahu says
there's no chance we think a premature
cessation of hostilities only plays into
hamas strategy
so you have refused we are not ready
for a ceasefire that allows hamas
time to regroup rest and then to attack
us again tomorrow or next week
in east jerusalem where this all began a
night of intense confrontations between
palestinian protesters
and israeli forces while in the occupied
west bank
similar scenes as hundreds of
palestinians took to the streets against
israel's provocations in jerusalem
and its assault on gaza on friday alone
10 palestinian protesters were killed
into clashes
with israeli soldiers it's hard to
imagine there's a potentially more
serious crisis unfolding in the
background of
all this unrest but across israel in
mixed arab and jewish cities
there's been several nights of horrific
communal violence
with the israeli-palestinian peace
process virtually non-existence
and this violence seeming to just spiral
out of control
the concern now is this could all lead
to an intifada
or palestinian uprising which could open
up a very dark
new chapter in this already long long
conflict
dana mts thank you